do you have anyone that looks like you
have you had any people come out of the
woodwork that's like a doppelganger just
yeah I'm hearty I have some maybe the
hearty part like you know that we all
have someone somewhere in the world that
looks exactly like us
I guess and when you're famous the
chances of you meeting that person go up
I have someone in Portland that looks
exactly like me do you have a picture
sorry
bourbon underscore Pilates she's gonna
potty spotty
like David Blaine
certainly does David playing with Down's
siggy can you see the moon see we were
googling statistics that I was trying to
catch up I'm really driving that to make
this podcasting let's see let's see your
topple can you try a Lancome pop gets it
relax is that her that's her Wow she
just look oh my god no I'll go down you
go down
yeah tell me what she but we also like
move alike and like talk alike that's
her right that's her that's her daughter
hold on keep going down keep going down
that's her reading my book that's like
there's lots of stuff we both got glass
is all like bottom let like see in the
striped shirt like just at that angle
that's us in the same photo oh my god
it's kind of wild that as well that's
[ __ ] yeah sure that's fair oh not Oman
to that bro I'm gonna still want
attention for about a sip no I'm saying
as far as do you think she has
just in that frame told her the other
one yes
that's pretty uncanny actually it's
pretty wild look at this one that one
that last one you I would swear these
kind of I would swear that you come on
that looks like yeah that one looks at
certain pictures yeah certain like
that's just gangers II like I mean it'd
be any closer it'd be a crier that's
yeah any closer would be a lahar me yeah
you guys thought about fooling your
resources and just don't some guy no I
did I was like I want a t-shirt like her
on that thing above that I don't know
anything about Pilates equipment her
Pilates as hard as [ __ ] really I heard
it's really hard okay I don't know why
we're watching of course we thought that
that might be a good video for some
reason have you seen that documentary
triplets yeah yo that's a mind [ __ ] I
gotta watch look at that I mean with the
baby when her mouth is open she's
smiling you guys like says things like
corners of our mouths and your eyebrows
you can hair come on that looks a lot of
weird eyebrows maybe that's a
doppelganger yeah that's as opposed to
as my nostrils are I wouldn't I would
think that's you in a picture what do
you think yes so you haven't found
anybody if you guys have doppelgangers
that look like these to a couple of guys
but I know some jujitsu guy they always
tell me the worst is when someone comes
up to you everyone tells me we look
alike and you're like my god hurtful
that looks like [ __ ] yeah so when she
yelled it out someone's like my friend
looks like you I was like here we go
this is about to hurt my feelings
look at that video with the circle thing
know it sounds funny that moves this is
the first one I saw that kind of blew my
mind yeah she looks a lot like it it's
not I mean come on it doesn't get much
closer I agree
but I'm surprised people what I'm your
judge I haven't said anything Choji I
don't think you guys look that much
alike really really no I do come on
same shape face like you're sitting
around as a different dad who's Hispanic
no you're crazy it's amazing how you
can't see that well no I see how you
guys see it I don't you're I promise it
I don't think it's like a homerun
do you guys I think she loved facial she
may be runny Glasson outnumbered but the
I can't believe no one's come out of the
woodwork and they have there's some guy
place for Liverpool's name for his name
he's a midfielder for Liverpool everyone
tags
he's a month you start talking you look
like the murderer I remember we used to
go to lunch and people thought your own
Hernandez yes yeah a shaved head there
was a mom it's a murder there's this
moment where any time we would go like
hang out someone would be look at you
and you be like that person had a shaved
head when he was on drugs when he was
hot is when he's popping when he's on
trial when he murdered like seven people
yeah that's right yeah yeah that's right
not bad not a bad he died yeah commit
suicide that's awful
what's he not gonna get out no no I
don't have people I'm just gonna text
you the restaurant I let my cleaning
people and like you could just pay you
know like take a month off and okay I'm
not I'm mentally need a break like you
can say that you sure so I can go do I
might go on my vacation where do I go on
vacation yeah I I want to see this I
went the last great vacation I went on
was the Maldives and then it's a great
it was amazing you want with you it's
amazing yes very worth going really it's
also sinking so it's not gonna be around
much longer it's hopefully there is
everything far right not that far I
don't people like you [ __ ] Drive
Renan that's everyone tagged me in him
together it's the square hairline and
the general I feel like me and him look
as much as you and that random girl
Phantogram know well you're not the same
ethnicity as this person I look just
like Zidane we might be I wish I don't
know what it is
have you figured out have you done in
23andme have you figured out watch I
never sent in the stuff I don't want to
find out Emery can't amrican I know a
lot of people who are finding out their
parents aren't their parents I see why
people think you look alike
I mean um sort of but I'm Raquel and I'm
like he's a stood yeah yeah yeah okay
not know that hair looks such a helmet
de pili yeah that looks like Steve rent
is easy okay yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]